[Music]
hello welcome back to off the record
where we're talking about whatever
we are today we are talking about
whether you would like your alcoholic
beverage to taste to be able to taste
the alcohol in it
i say that a well-mixed beverage you
shouldn't taste the alcohol but it still
gets you messed up
i drink absolutely not false
can only drink whiskey i can only drink
this
and macallan in that case you should
drink it straight and you should wash
your alcohol you should pour some so we
can cherish
okay you don't like taste you don't like
you like the alcohol
i don't like uh i don't like my my drink
tasting not like alcohol because if i'm
ordering an alcoholic drink
it i better know this alcohol in there
he doesn't get ripped off i don't want
to get ripped off that's a fine man of
the deals
yeah i like to know i always go can i
get a
moscow meal version i say like that
moscow milk conversion here's the thing
so that way they
they everyone thinks i'm a man for
ordering at the counter
but then no one heard that i don't want
any alcohol in there and then bart's
like
did i mention i'm i'm an ex-marine
bart always gets the most fruitiest
drinks too and i always have to follow
palatine
virgin and i'm still a man yeah virgin
with a little umbrella and all that i'm
like oh that looks good it really does
do that though where he drinks it he's
like
oh it's strong but you know it's not too
strong
i have i bartended yeah and
you gotta do the [ __ ] absolutely not
do you dance on the stage like coyote
ugly style and boom
i don't i wasn't supposed to but i have
i've definitely
yeah i'm not your typical bartender i
just i really wasn't that good at the
job i was good at the like
hey come see me hang out let's get
[ __ ] up let's get drunk
you still get tips oh i'm that's what
i'm there for hella tips i am there for
the tip
can you put like three bottles in one
hand and go yes
i could but i wasn't very good like like
i was saying i'm not very good but you
could tell
it all over you make the guys go out and
you spill your like you can't do that
anymore no
you can't because of corona no no pre
because it's like uh
alcohol poisoning oh you can like hit
their teeth feminism
like you can hit their teeth and you can
like stab them so it's not very safe
because the spouts are metal
but you can tell a lot about somebody
based off of what they drink but
sometimes
i mean a restaurant ordering a cocktail
in a restaurant is completely different
than going to like a bar
or a club because of corporate pores
it's [ __ ] you get the [ __ ] deals
when you can taste the liquor i actually
agree so if you are on a budget get an
amf get a long island get a shot don't
go for a mixed drink like don't red
bull's always extra side note have you
guys ever been to a papasan beer
in like mexico i've been there before it
is the kind of place that
will not exist in america for sure
because it's like
they're known for doing like if you're
gonna go there you know what's gonna
happen right what's gonna happen and
they
like you're gonna get an std maybe
honestly
that was the place where they abducted
me and jess off the street and they took
us into poverty
it took our shorts
you're trying to get drinks whatever
they'll pick you up from your table uh
pour the drink in your mouth uh flip you
upside down you're wearing a dress or
not doesn't matter
like things are gonna flip out they'll
pull down your shirt even it's crazy
wow they were taking off and i was like
nah
we're out of here kidnapped after a
cruise and i was like this cannot exist
he had to come rescue us he was like no
no no no no no no
i wasn't being flippable did you have
fun when that was happening no she was
terrified so
people have fun though oh everyone was
laughing and having fun like i
i knew like i'm like okay maybe it's
safe because like everyone's like having
fun it's in a restaurant and everyone's
getting flipped over on somebody
i think full-on were like unbuttoning
oh no no no no no no no no no
this is me and my buddy joe and his now
ex-wife jess
and then justice and joe's don't belong
and so and that's true we were all
together and they were
literally just stripping these chicks
down on the bar we weren't even in the
restaurant we were just kind of like
what's that place and then all of a
sudden these guys pick us up
hey so it's not even girls coming to get
you it's dudes no dudes
no i'm calling bart for backup on that
one you grabbed the wrong
bar toothpaste and they were like don't
call bart for that they don't
like um they were talking to our men
they were like they're like hey do shots
off them do shots off them and like
strangers oh my god joe's going to be
bailing me out of jail for beating
somebody up because they try to pull my
long ass off them straight
long ass long ass out them streets
that's why just don't call bart because
people will die
yeah how could we have to have bored i
could do it
but you don't come with toothpaste
that's true or the eyes she's never seen
another video where bart talked about
how he's gonna torture people to back up
his friend
and so you also didn't train for years
to be able to put your hand through a
wind a car window pull a guy out of it
you know why that's why he's buff the
only reason why he's buffed
is because window he realized that he
wasn't strong enough to break a window
and pull a guy out of the car that was
my dream in high school
but that's what motivated me so you've
trained for that day was there something
where you saw a guy in a car and you're
like i need to get them out of there and
i can't do it right now but one day i
will
no i had uh i mean we got it's a lot of
fights in high school
and then they were always in cars in
europe they weren't always in cars but
like you know sometimes like you get
into a fight and then there's like a guy
that's like running away
and then one of my older homies i saw
how he was able to not let people run
away when he was beating him up and i'm
like that's pretty cool ah
so you train for the one that's trying
to flee the scene
before in high school but then i fell in
love with actually working out and like
because you know being big has nothing
to do with catching the guy right
exactly exactly
your thing slows you down yeah it gets
in the way a little bit did you tell
your karate instructor because they
would have hated that [ __ ] unless
they're copper cops no our our
karate teacher was like cobra kai was he
yeah
he would get into fist fights at bars
and stuff
and like if he found out you had some
conflict and it didn't end in violence
he'd probably like you need to tell that
guy to come here
but not in class right because in class
we're like yo guys just so you know
this is not this is he's pretty open
about violence
like if let's say me and joe if we
weren't sparring hard enough he'd like
he'll split us up stop
and then he'll go and beat joe's ass and
then joe sit down then come and beat my
ass
that's how it's supposed to be done you
know the nice thing about it that's why
he has less and less students every
single month yeah
sometimes i feel like you go to like a
martial arts studio and you look at like
the people teaching and i'm like i don't
know if you could actually fight
anyone you ever see that yeah yes i was
i was raised june karate bro i did june
read taekwondo
and it was jim how do you spell this
he's like a famous
karate guy look him up he he wore a gold
korean bruce lee showman type dude yeah
but
he would um before we did the
tournaments he would always come and he
wasn't always there
it was he had a chain so he like hired
taekwondo franchise sacramento
franchises he was the first mcdojo
which is what you guys told me yeah
mcdojo is like like where it's not real
karate it's like
a chain character doing it for the
business not really for the art yeah so
he would before the tournaments he would
make us all he would come out the
goalkeeper he would give a speech
like a keynote address and then he would
make us all watch him do like [ __ ] a
thousand push-ups
like we're all just like watching our
[ __ ]
old guy oh yeah he was he was a machine
he was really good too it's not about
that but
it's about what he did with this with
his franchises yeah so like getting
drunk in a bar and
having that experience under your belt
probably not going to help anybody out
no dude i did that [ __ ] when i was like
five years old i don't [ __ ] remember
anything
i was just like yo guys i'll do push-ups
yeah yeah
you just start doing push-ups stop the
conflict
look at this yeah i gotta do a thousand
of these guys
bear with me just wait right there you
warmed up nikki i'm just like
okay try to nick you try to button up
your pants now
i think i did end up doing a shot off of
your navel and joe
too because we kind of were being polite
and then we left papas and beer
like this is part of the culture well
they already poured it and i was like
that's free
[Laughter]
was it free they didn't charge you no
they didn't charge the [ __ ] all i
remember is i went to the bathroom wait
so they just be pouring alcohol out
for those kinds we also went we also
went to like a little shop and these
guys were just giving us
tequila shots let's just be real i don't
think anybody's flipping me over and we
all threw up after them
let's be real i don't think they're i
don't think they go we want that one
and like try to interact no no they they
but they they they're big dudes i feel
like they look at it as like challenges
sometimes
and like and there's like three of them
holding you yeah the flipping over thing
is is not one of the random things that
they do
to you that's see this is why i wear
body suits in case anybody tries to flip
me over
you won't see it stays intact it's got
to be
entertaining for some people right
that's why they keep doing it no yeah
people come for it
yeah like like men and women come forth
for that experience it's very odd it
sounds like a cancun
type like exactly that's exactly that
kind of thing i've seen that i mean
could you land there from a cruise
i feel like i want to do that one time
but just like nobody have their phones
out
i'd be down okay i'd be down if like
nobody had their phones is it all you
don't snatch me up do they grab them i
wanna i want you willingly i'll help
other people to grab
that'll be funny i didn't stay to find
out i was like grandma out of here oh
those are fine
that would be fun that would be fun i'll
be crazy see your grandma go crazy
and you know what's crazy the economy
right now
today's video is brought to you by
upstart baby
yeah so there's a lot of economic
chatter right now about the state of the
market is it recovering how long will it
take
have we seen the worst of it we don't
know but if you're struggling to pay off
high interest credit card debt
you can't wait for those answers you
need to take action and now with upstart
there's actually something you can do
today to help fight off the high
interest credit card debt upstart is the
revolutionary online lending platform
that knows
you're more than just a credit score
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your job history in the
form of a smarter rate
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from a thousand to
fifty thousand dollars big money so you
can consolidate your debt into one easy
fixed rate payment
upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate since it's just a soft
pull
it won't affect your credit score the
hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
the best part
if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day
see why upstart has over 6 000 five-star
reviews on trustpilot
so hurry up to upstart.com record
to find out how low your up start rate
can be checking your rate only takes a
few minutes that's upstart.com
record and your loan about your loan
amount will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application not
all applicants will qualify for the full
amount
check it out speaking of
money and loans and things like that so
like
you know how we were talking about
dating during the break right so
there's a there's like hell of dudes
that
think that just because you have money
you have chances of getting hotter girls
and all this stuff
and you know they there's some guys that
trickle on to my insta and talk about
that [ __ ] too
and then like when they talk about like
us and they're like of course like yeah
yo joe's loaded like he's
she's she wants to hang out with them
and all that and i'm all like little do
they know
i have zero in the bank account cause
it's all invested in this [ __ ] and
little does he know i'm the one making
the money that's right take us out to
eat
right but it is she's the one that got
the pork chops last time
i did yeah it's it is weird that guys
like to make that reference because like
what the [ __ ] am i doing like do i not
have a job do i not work like
like so i just have nothing to bring to
the table they all say
i mean i don't know who these guys are
though because i haven't met them in
real life
like because you're not around that
group yeah i only see them online where
they're like
girls want to take all your money or
whatever i'm like whoo like
don't go for those girls then why they
act like they don't have a choice
between
we're the moochers if you think about it
right because geo was supporting bart
yeah i'm always gaining with girls who
had better jobs titles and
everything than me she's smarter than me
she's running the finances in your
relationship
yeah i put it all on bitcoin yeah
i'm working very hard to eventually
become a stay-at-home dad definitely
that's awesome yeah
she has a sick ass job over at what
tesla right or
uh jpl okay are you trying to have a kid
eventually
like soon house have you been blessed
what do you mean by
things no
it's really weird when they say that
though it's like
why can't there be a balance it's like
these guys
it's like how insecure are you yeah i
think it's just people projecting and
they think that they can't do it unless
they have money so they're assuming
everyone else
they think that that's the reason
they're being rejected like oh they
won't
go or they won't go for me because i'm
not tall enough for what i'm like no
maybe
you just have a shitty personality girls
like so if you're attractive like you
have to be stupid and not be able to
fend for yourself like that's kind of
what the internet thinks if you're
good-looking you can't be smart and you
don't get anything on your own
it's the same mentality as the
middle-aged white guy who gets a
corvette
and he's like i'm about to [ __ ] scoop
up the [ __ ] it's gonna be [ __ ]
flipping up my windshield it's all
men that give them attention like yo
dumb car bro
cool corvette i got one too man yeah
cool and all the girls are like
midlife crisis it's like we know what
this looks like then they pull out the
keys to get a little corvette keychain
on it like
hey honey and it's like dude i know how
much that is like 50 grand like you know
if you're out there just trying to get
money to pick up [ __ ] like that's all
you're gonna do
get money and pick up you're looking for
those type of girls then
and but do that though stop being a
hater like well which kind of [ __ ]
cost the least
what does that work yeah what's the deal
yeah which ones cost
the least amount you know what i'm
saying like guys that think they can
only get
chicks because of money or because of
like their job or what they look like
have no
[ __ ] personality because if you're
dope you're like i'm dope she should
want me because i'm done be financially
responsible
but like both you know if they feel like
they act like only one person is making
the money like most people i feel like
both incomes are involved yeah i think
it's like not a fair conversation
because nobody here would i would be
like so how would you feel about having
to support a girl
100 you know i think that you guys love
whoever you're with
and it's gonna be like yeah that's what
you do relationships you you figure it
out
the thing is is that i would right but
then like we we both do things that we
love so
which also provide for us so that it's
it's great yeah i would not feel
i would feel like so bored if i didn't
or if i wasn't working
yeah or like not working on something or
doing yeah the guys that do this and
just like they're wondering i think
they're genuinely inquiring because it's
like what am i doing wrong
but they don't know how to say that they
just go and become defensive and be like
oh he must have money it's like it's
easier to blame someone else and be like
oh the reason of for their success or
i they have what i don't have because
they're lucky they're born this it's
victim mentality yeah
i was listening to this podcast and um
there's like a special group of asian
dudes that
subscribe to this really in-cell
mentality they're specifically asian
specifically asian guys on this podcast
they were talking about how
like um uh
they're undesirable because they're
short and this and that and then i was
like
don't bring me into this don't bring my
friends into this
like this is not a cultural thing like
we're not undesirable like i never had
this thought
or this problem saying that out loud is
so bad but
but they're like oh you know because
well and they were talking to other
asian guys and then they were like well
we just kind of talked to the girls
because oh well it's because you're tall
guys like me like we don't we don't and
i'm like thinking
tim's not tall but i've seen him with
some really pretty girls and i'm like
it's never
that like what they're just there for
the money yeah it blows my freaking mind
personality will
always be on the forefront because think
about it at the end of the day like i
said if you just want
girls that want you for your money
you're gonna find girls that only want
you for your money
and if you want somebody to like you for
you you'll find somebody who likes you
for you
stop putting people on a [ __ ] pistol
when you don't even know them right
that's the whole thing absolutely when
people got problems
i've never met somebody who's out of my
league or whatever because i don't treat
people like that like i just treat
people like people
and if i if i happen to get along with
them and then like something happens
where we are romantic that's [ __ ]
awesome
but it's like i don't treat them like oh
my god like you must be so like
and like i'm just so ugh but when you do
that you just make yourself like nuclear
well
yeah but i think all of the guys in jk
we date women that are out of our
leagues of course we do like and even
before jk started but we don't act like
it and they don't feel like that of your
legs because they like you're offering
value
no i mean like if we stood next to each
other right like
it's just physically like we are not
matchy it's insane dude it's like
looking at the the bitcoin gains versus
like [ __ ] xrp right
and so that's why people go it's because
he has money it's because of this it's
because of that yeah
it's like nah i married him because he's
a stud he's 10 out of 10 things like
things like a horse you know steve got a
big ass dick yeah
every time you guys talk about that i'm
like i can't even make eye contact with
him it's just still up nobody's balls
are bigger than like this look at me
nothing he's a cutie
look at me you you and your girl make a
you guys matchy matchy
no it wasn't about my girlfriend i had a
conversation about this recently it was
really like random i was like playing
games and then i don't know where the
streamer like joined the party right
when you play games someone could just
join your party
and he was in the middle of talking to
his audience at the time and he was like
oh excuse me i'm just having a therapy
session with my
viewers and then someone was like oh i'm
in love with this girl
who like like she doesn't even like me
whatever but i like i love her blah blah
blah
how can you love someone that's not
you're not even in a relationship with
so that we're playing this game
which is just like a casual video game
but he's just like giving this therapy
session of like you know you're just in
love with like how can you be in love
with just someone by their looks
and then like you don't really know who
who they are because they're playing
among us or something
like something something casual like
that yeah how can you shoot this [ __ ]
like this
he he is and then i started joining
another conversation too i'm like that's
true man like
how how can you you can't just like you
can't just be in love with someone and
they don't love you back
and like put them on this pedestal
because now you feel like they're the
one and in reality there isn't just the
one and we start
having this deep conversation as we're
running around trying to kill people
that's cute in my day we would have said
you guys are [ __ ] and i would have left
the server
that's the truth not not anymore but
that's that wasn't my day i wouldn't say
that now
i wouldn't say that now i couldn't it's
just not steve from a 12 year old boy
playing call of duty or something on
twit like the internet
is the funniest place because you'll
randomly be talking about something else
and you just see somebody like
how give me dating advice or i need love
advice it's like you guys are on the
wrong platform sometimes y'all are
asking these deep questions on the wrong
places yeah slide in the dm send a
paragraph over so that they can
privately answer you
that's true yeah because on my twitch
stream i don't need your [ __ ]
oh what if they probably messaged you
like listen i know you're not gonna be
interested
i hate that if you start off if you
start off
i know you're not going to read this so
i'll take your questions right now i'm
not going to respond
to you you become the story you tell
yourself
but please choose a fulfilling prophecy
like you're never going to see this but
i'm like yo just be cool
just be cool i try my best to respond
don't preface things
i always get um you look intimidating
or you're probably a [ __ ] or what yeah
really cool way to start off a
conversation hi
[ __ ] or i thought you were gonna be
like a [ __ ] anyway
are you interested i knew you wouldn't
be coming on here coming on here they
were like i thought you were just a
[ __ ] before and you actually have like
a personality i'm like
we're [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah wow
i get i get a lot of that like oh i saw
you out and you look super intimidating
i didn't you know want to say anything
but now that people get to see my
personality more they're like oh you're
actually pretty cool
but yes i do get that some women or men
look super intimidating by like their
photos like i'm not posting the smiley
happy photos
that's also because i don't want people
to always you know i'm just trying to be
fierce i'm trying to get face
uh and of course she got the [ __ ] me
face on do i
mm-hmm you like it okay so you know now
you know that you don't have to sign
into my dms anymore because you heard
what he said
that's right that's it but dude i've
been in rooms with lots of powerful
people right
i've been around billionaires before and
[ __ ] you don't treat them like they're
better than you
you just talk to them like the regular
people they give you free money if you
don't do that
how do you get free money from them if
you don't know you gotta just [ __ ]
you know
you gotta just be yourself a little bit
because if you go in there acting like
like oh like i know you're never gonna
do them
that's all i'm saying when i say i've
never been anybody who's out of my
league because you don't treat people
like that
you just treat people like you treat
anybody and then you realize that
nobody's really special and everyone's
just kind of in their own situation
trying to feel everyone out yeah
self-confidence is really what it is
it's self-confidence and it takes time
yo if you are one of those
i got you and if you're if you're one of
those people that maybe sent that
message and you're kind of feeling a
little attacked right now you could just
take it as a moment to be like yo okay
let's let's switch this up a little bit
maybe i'm way better than i give myself
credit for because if you put yourself
down that negative self-talk ain't it
learn from it stop dming here
[Music]
so